i don't care he says
everything's cool i'm gonna be a bigger
person should i blow up this guy's house
with his family in it
hiding yo chris matt
what's up boys hope you guys are doing
well directing traffic this is
san diego
and i'm calling for some advice on this
situation that i'm in so
i did this girl for like six years um
and i had a homie who was like my friend
for like 12 years oh
it's like one of those friends that like
in you know like at points you guys were
best friends and then you spread apart
and then yeah
whatever
so whatever dated this girl for six
years we didn't work out i was toxic as
[ __ ] whatever
um
and then after
whatever we broke up they're now dating
uh um oh we know it
right
so and
i'm asking for advice not on whether or
not it's right or wrong because actually
i don't care that they're dating
oh
look at the girl phone
oh look at the drone he's gone now i
believe i'm calling because
is it wrong of me if i were to ever come
across this guy
to slap the dog [ __ ] out of him yeah i
don't care he says hey
they're not like you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to you know who cares but
like there's a level of respect
that is betrayed when you do something
like that like
you know we're not we're not in the
[ __ ] we're not in 10th grade you know
like we're grown-ups we're not 10th
grade you just like beat them up if you
do some grown-up [ __ ] that's uh
disrespectful
you get your [ __ ] slapped for it you
know what i'm saying so yeah i don't
know what you think am i wrong for
slapping this dude if i come across yeah
i mean this guy dude this is one of my
favorite ones we ever got just [ __ ]
last week a buddy of mine whose
girlfriend recently broke up with him
found out accidentally that
he him and his girlfriend were put
together for 15 years he was living
together they were living with a
roommate okay who was like the friend of
theirs
and he found out after she broke up with
him and didn't say anything about this
yeah that they were [ __ ] under his
nose in his house for like who knows up
to a year or whatever and now they're
going to move in with each other
all the while the guy still lives with
the [ __ ] girl well the guy still
lives with my friend the woman moved out
but the guy still had his shoulder to
cry on and [ __ ] until the other day when
he found out
yeah dude just evil [ __ ]
but
that guy didn't beat up
the guy so i mean that's much worse than
what this guy's [ __ ] dealing with i
mean dude you just gotta let it you
gotta let this guy's like i don't care
but should i just you know look
everything's cool i don't care i'm fine
i'm well past it everything's cool i'm
gonna be a bigger person should i blow
up this guy's house with his family in
it like you just knew it was yeah yeah
yeah
guitar licks
just
just don't do that okay let it go it's
all good they both did you a [ __ ]
favor
and just [ __ ] you know also it's
after like they weren't cheating
yeah
right i mean it's still annoying if it
was his friend you know but doors don't
you
yeah then you're kind of being a [ __ ]
bro don't you don't beat someone up
don't beat somebody he's like you know
we're not in high school anymore if
you're not high school anymore then just
be an adult about it be like you know
what [ __ ] them and also what do you
think was going to happen you know what
i mean like that's what happened i've
said this
about i'll say this about everything
like this all the time the best way to
quote get back at someone for that [ __ ]
is to
not give a [ __ ] about it live and live
the best
don't give a [ __ ] about it and then soon
after that inward because you see the
results of outwardly not giving a [ __ ]
about it you will also on the inside not
give a [ __ ] about it yeah it's kind of
like the fake it till you make it thing
don't give a [ __ ] about it that is the
best [ __ ] revenge because then you're
telling them
you guys don't [ __ ] matter yeah i
don't even give a [ __ ] about you i don't
even remember who are you who is this
[ __ ] person yeah yeah oh he dated no
he didn't i don't know who you are also
what if you lose the fight right that's
not good at all you know what i mean
then he took the girl and you got your
[ __ ] ass kicked you just don't it's
just there's too many variables like
also what if you get he they [ __ ]
calls the police that's the big thing
like what if you really [ __ ] them up you
get right like you don't manslaughter
dude
curb stomp him right i just think
there's too many things that could go
wrong plus
it's not a good look after that
you know 30 like a [ __ ] month six
months a year
as time goes on you're gonna less and
less like the fact that you did that yes
oh totally just a hundred percent you're
gonna be 60 and you're gonna be talking
to your kids yeah like you know your
father regrets something yes exactly
yeah i need to get it off my chest i
don't know why you'd be morgan freeman
when you grew up but
hello
[Music]